As we look at what is happening
over the last decade, the word woke.
You've heard it a lot
in the last couple of years.
It's gone from what was a battlecry,
a prominent hashtag used by Black Lives
Matter protesters.
To a political buzzword.
It's a catchall umbrella term
that seemingly is used to describe
people on ideas that conservatives
just don't like.
The thing is, even former
President Trump is acknowledging that
the word has really lost its meaning
as he continues to use it.
And I don't like the term work
because I hear work.
Work well connotes, I guess, a term that
used half the people can't even define it.
They don't know what it is.
But of things going on with our military,
with the Woke and all this nonsense
and they're not learning to fight
and protect us from some very bad people.
They want to go
woke. They want to go woke.
An irony there, but.
Yes, yes.
Let's bring in CNN political commentator
and New York magazine columnist
Errol Louis. Errol, good morning.
Do you think it is
ironic that now we have Republicans
arguing among themselves
about what woke is and what woke isn't?
Because I'm old enough to remember
just a few years ago
when woke with something
very different Yes.
Yes. Those are 36 months ago,
an entirely new, different universe.
Well, yeah,
look, it's it's typical of Trump
to sort of change the terms of the debate
as it suits him in the moment.
He can do that.
He can execute those kind of flip flops
within one speech, actually.
And his followers
are not that interested in the niceties
or the particular is of being consistent
about this or that term.
And so look what he has done.
And I, I can't believe that the Republican
challengers don't quite get this yet,
but what he has done
since 20, 15, since 2016,
or throughout his political career,
what he has done is just redefined
and scrambled. What politics is
the the De Santos's eyes of the world.
All of these other traditional
politicians are acting as if voters
have some list of issues.
And if your promises match their list of
issues, then they're going to support you.
That is not
what Trump's support is about at all.
It is about him and him personally
and what it means.
Whatever he decides,
it means that day, in that moment,
and his followers are not particularly
interested in any of the rest of it.
And I think Ron DeSantis
is going to discover that as he fails
to close the gap, the 20 to 30 point gap
between him and Donald Trump,
there is a larger that sort of
if we take that 30,000 foot
view of what the term has come to me
and really what it symbolizes
and it's also
it feels like it has become this license.
Right?
Or maybe it's that it's
underscoring the shift in this country
to grievance politics, real or imagined.
And mostly imagined in many cases
that all of a sudden there
is this comfort level and almost
an encouragement to attack anyone in
anything that is different from you
and somehow blame
whatever ills you or bothers you on
whatever is different,
either how someone feels or looks,
whatever it may be, So it's become also
when I see it, it's become this effort to
run on exclusion as opposed to inclusion.
And it seems sadly effective
Oh, yeah, it's very effective.
Listen, the election of Donald Trump
was the primal scream of the white
working class that thinks that Washington
is lying to them.
Wall Street is exploiting them
and Hollywood is laughing at them.
And that hasn't gone away.
And really,
it just all now consolidates into
this idea
that we've got these enemies out there
and we're going to support the person
who helps us fight against them.
And that's what January six was about.
And that's what the Trump
phenomenon is about.
And that's what the presidential election
is going to be about,
at least the Republican primary
is going to be about.
And so woke is just like
sort of a nice little buzz word.
It kind of consolidates the whole thing.
And it's them who are causing the problem
that might be immigrants,
that might be people of color,
that might be the,
you know, education from K through 12
all the way through the academy
about ideas and books
that you're not comfortable with.
The transgender movement, LGBTQ rights,
all of it gets dumped together in one
sack.
And people say like,
there's this woke stuff, diversity,
you know, we don't want diversity.
We don't want the we don't want inclusion.
It's like, okay, you don't want anything.
Those like that's fine.
But, you know, it's a good way
to lose a general election, by the way.
But it is a very real movement
there are people who feel very put upon.
They have good reason to.
Frankly, there's an economic underpinning
to all of this that is very real.
People are losing their livelihoods,
losing their jobs.
The deindustrialization of the country
has not stopped.
And so, you know, the politicians
who want to exploit
that are really what we're seeing.
They're really kind of driving the bus
at this point.
Errol, unfortunately,
we don't have a lot of time left.
But you say here
that some of Donald Trump's challengers
are not understanding
what his support really is about.
So what would a third candidate
and not not add the Santés,
but a third candidate
need to do to really swing things
in their favor if they're misunderstanding
the Trump support right now?
Well, I think the Republican Party
and those who wants to lead it
have been putting this off
for a long, long time.
But they're going to really have to
sort of decide
what are the principles
on which this party is based.
And then they have to go on a massive,
massive educational program
to try and talk to people about what they
believe about free markets,
about, you know,
evangelical Christianity,
and morality and politics and so forth.
You don't hear people talking about that.
It's really more
this kind of tribal poll of
those are your enemies
and I'll go smash them for you.
That's not how you do it, is that? Yeah.
I mean,
and they've now gravitated to somebody
who's a master of that kind of politics.
And his name happens to be Donald Trump.
Or what's going to be a lot to watch.
And it's only doing
so only to just kind of say something to
the good news is
we'll get to see a lot of you.
So that's a win. Thanks. There we go.